[Music]
thank you good evening and welcome to
this
extraordinary council meeting on tuesday
23rd of february
2021 my name is councillor mark hurd and
i'm chairman of the malden district
council
this meeting is held under new
regulations which come into effect
on the 4th of april in response to the
covid
19 situation and there are just a few
housekeeping issues
to run through first of all could ask
everyone present at this meeting to
ensure that your microphone remains
muted when not addressing the council
and this will reduce background noises
and any unintentional
disturbances this meeting is being
hosted
remotely streamed live and recorded and
by being present in the meeting
you are giving your consent to being
recorded
members and officers during each item
please use the hands up function
of the meeting to indicate if you wish
to speak and i will then invite you at
the appropriate time
members are reminded that apart from
indicating points of order that you have
or that you have to leave the meeting
the chat function should not be used for
questions or any other purpose
when speaking and referring to the
agenda papers please ensure you
reference a page or paragraph number
and keep your contributions as clear and
concise as possible
when invited to speak please ensure that
your microphone is on
now may i ask officers taking part in
the meeting
to introduce themselves starting with mr
dodson
good evening members paul dodson
director of strategy performance and
governance
thank you mr dodson mr leslie
good evening chris leslie director of
resources
good evening uh mr holmes good evening
members richard holmes director of
service delivery
thank you mr quelch
simon simon quelch a legal advisor for
the council
thank you mrs longman
uh chairman i don't believe she's with
us tonight sorry about that my apologies
that's all right that brings me to the
next one then miss bird
good evening members tara bird committee
services officer thank you very much
sorry jack longman is here i couldn't
find my move button
welcome jackie nice nice to see you
thank you
um and uh i think uh burner is here as
well
just back up chairman all right thank
you very much
any other officers present please
okay thank you um tara can ask you to
call out
uh the roll call of members to confirm
who
is in attendance please thank you yes
tim before i do that just to advise
there
we do have a few other additional
offices and we've got
matthew winslow lance porteous stephen
butcher
and sue green i believe oh hannah
wheatley as well are also on the meeting
with us
thank you and remember if you could just
indicate if you're present when i call
your name please
starting with councillor bassinger
please
good evening everyone i'm president
thank you councilman spiel
good evening present that's the brian
beale
good evening everyone i'm present your
counselor voice
yeah council mrs channel
i'm here yeah same problem as jackie
thank you
councillor durham present
councillor edwards he remembers
present mrs fleming
present thank you tara you canceled
president thank you councillor heard
councillor helm good evening present
counselor hull good evening everybody
yes i'm here thank you councillor jarvis
evening tara chairman members thank you
very much
excuse me go around to all of us
good evening thank you councillor mays
good evening
good evening tara present thank you casa
morris
good evening and welcome good evening
thank you
councillor none yes good evening sorry
evening members present
thank you cancer shawnee good evening
tara present
thank you cancer good evening tara good
evening chairman president
thank you cancer schemes good evening
everybody
thank you cancer stamp yeah good evening
tara chairman and members
presidents and officers thank you thank
you cancer stilts
good evening everybody present thank you
cancer
yes tara good evening thank you thank
you councillor miss white
um i'm present good
[Music]
mr thompson sorry apologies
he's present as well he wasn't called
out sorry but
hello present members good evening tara
good evening
thank you tara could we just confirm
councillor brian beal is with us
please he has just joined chairman yes
thank you chairman casamay's has got a
hand up
councillor mays uh yeah thank you mr
chairman i was just going to say uh
uh councillor beal is he's trying to
join us but he's
he's made it in thank you thank you very
much
gender item number two uh apologies for
as
absence might have any apologies for
absence please tara
uh yes chairman we just got one from
councillor dueck thank you very much
thank you very much agenda item number
three
is declaration of interest
this is to disclose the existence and
nature of any disclosable pecuniary
interests
other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests relating to
items of business on the agenda
having regret to paragraphs six to eight
inclusive of the code of conduct for
members
members are reminded that they're also
required to disclose any such
interest as soon as they become aware
should the need arise
throughout the meeting the local
government finance act 1992
section 106 asks that any member
affected by section 106 please note that
any declarations to that effect
should be made on the commencement of
the meeting or immediately on arrival
if this is later under section 106 a
member who has not paid an amount due in
respect of their council tax
for at least two months after it became
payable
is precluded from voting on any matters
affecting the level of council tax or
the arrangements
for administering the council tax
the member is however entitled to speak
so i'll now refer to the lead legal
specialist and monitoring officer
who will give a short update regarding a
dispensation
granted by the joint standards committee
at its meeting
yesterday mr quelch
yeah thank you very much um chairman um
yes um yesterday afternoon the
standards committee gave a dispensation
to councillor stephen nunn um he had
made a request
by email under section 33 of the
localism act
and although because of my wrong advice
the joint standards committee made that
resolution for all members
that was entirely my mistake um
uh the resolution only applies to
uh counsellor nun because he's the only
one
that made the application and section 33
only applies to a can only apply to a
member who's made an application
for dispensation so counselor nun has
already disclosed
to me a disclo disclosable pecuniary
interest the joint
standards committee have therefore given
to him
a dispensation to remain in the meeting
to debate
and to vote on the budget
on all items of the budget chairman
thank you very much indeed uh so if any
member has an interest
an interest to declare please use the
hands up function
uh and i will invite you to speak
counsellor none
yes thank you chair i'm grateful to mr
quelch for explaining the situation
i do believe however i should still
declare
and i want to declare a pecuniary
interest as i believe it and i've
declared this
on previous occasions uh as it relates
to
fees and charges a small part of fees
and charges
anything to do with warfage or um
or the like for barges because my wife
uh works as a caterer for one of the
barge companies topsail charters
and pre-covered in happier times i used
to give guided tours
history tours from the barges so that's
why i've asked for dispensation
because it's one part of one part of
five
thank you thank you councillor none that
is noted councillor mays
thank you mr chairman um i'd like to
declare a non-pecuniary interest
in item 5c fees and charges as i am the
secretary for the modern and
um hey bridge heritage harbor
association
thank you thank you thank you very much
i have had a point of
order raised uh from councillor boyce
which what is your point of order please
councillor voice
um it relates to the local government
act 2011 section 33.
um chairman
yesterday i challenged um
mr kwelsh's report to the joint
standards and
said that it was out of order i also
said
that councilman nunn's interest was well
known because it was made
last year he then went on i think he's
just apologized
to wrongly inform the committee that
every member
would be able to benefit from this
i after checking with um
mr quelch to what the actual section was
i looked it up and it can only apply to
one member um
so therefore my point of order yesterday
i believe was correct and that this
shouldn't have come
forward and councillor nunn um
who has expressed his interest
is quite uh right um to do so
and i respect that but it was a decision
that we knew about and um
the officers tried to pull the wool
over councillor's eyes thank you
okay well i'm not i'm not sure there was
any uh wool
pulling uh but uh i i do remember that
uh you challenged whether it related to
all councillors but that has now been
corrected
uh it is counsellor none only
for this meeting and that will be
further discussed at the next
standards meeting so thank you for that
point of order
further further on that point of order
the point is that i made this
um state uh point of order yesterday
on this act and was and the committee
were advised wrongly
so therefore the decision that they made
is ultra virus
yes i understand that but as i attended
that meeting uh it was in fact
intended to be for councillor none
only uh it was then thrown open uh
to include all councillors uh which it
which it was
agreed um in my view
councillor nunn is one of the
councillors although he's specifically
named
uh and i'm sure that you wouldn't want
to create um democracy
council of voice so i'm i'm happy that
the
spirit of the decision has been met
so i'm going to move on now to uh
councillor
councillor durham to make his interest
known
thank you chairman uh chairman i have a
non-binary interest
as a member of essus county council and
also a non-binary interest asset i am a
governor of e-put that's
essex partnership university nhs trust
which is a voluntary position thank you
thank you very much councillor maurice
um i'll die i'd rather you uh let the
ladies and everyone else go first if you
don't mind please chair
okay thank you very much uh councillor
lagan
yes thank you chair it's a non-pecuniary
chess chair
in item number 5c please uh
discretionary fees and charges i'm also
a member of the malden
and hayward harbour commissioners and
i've also
had as members know conversations with
barge owners and operators over the
years
thank you chair thank you very much uh
councillor
um councillor schemes
uh yes it's really a clarification um
in budget meetings in general i declare
a pecuniary interest in connection with
uh
the uh west key houseboat association
that holds a lease with morton district
council
uh it's not really connected to 5c in
the barges on the waterfront
and i understand there was some
confusion about this at some stage so
i'm just clarifying
that should ever the west key house post
association's lease come up then i have
a pecuniary interest
in that particular item
okay thank you very much councillor
stiltz
thank you mr chairman um non-pecuniary
interest
in item 5c as i also sit on the
malden heritage harbour
committee and i also sit on the
committee for the little ship club
thank you very much councillor chana
um thank you chairman i wish to declare
a non-bikuni interest that i'm also a
member of essex county council
and it isn't named in various um reports
tonight
under the budget papers obviously
because of the relationship the council
has and also because of the precepts and
council tax setting
i also wish to declare non-pecuniary
chairman
regarding gender item number five and i
think it's a 5a the
um capital paper
uh the capital programme paper and uh
chairman i wish to claim non-procurement
that there's reference there
regarding um the houseboats there's
mention made of a vessel the lease helig
in the past i've always um can i sit on
the crouch harbor authority committee i
always
remove myself from the chamber when the
lease helic was discussed
however chairman i do believe i can
remain because regarding that vessel
things have moved on
so tonight is much more about the issue
of the houseboats and that capital
project
but i um therefore can remain chairman
i've also just for information never
participated in discussions when the
crouch harbor authority committee
may have had discussions on lies helig
thank you very much uh councillors boyce
and durham you still have your hand up
i don't know if that's a um legacy hand
or not
thank you i'll also declare a
non-pecuniary interest
in uh agenda item 5c in that i am a
trustee
of the steam tug brent uh which is
uh moored at uh malden although i don't
have any involvement with the
any finances on that so it's
non-pecuniary um
i think i have uh
one more i think or two more councillor
edwards
thank you chairman um non-pecuniary
interest item
5c wolf chargers i'm a member of the
thames bard selling trust thank you
thank you very much i other than
councillor
morris are there any other hands at all
tyra
no chairman i believe that's the only
one that's left thank you okay
councillor morris
thank you chairman i'd just like to
point out that our monitoring officer
has made
yet another mistake um due to
the monitoring officer's mistake i'm a
little bit uh odds
at exactly what i should be doing right
now
but i'd just like to point out to the
rest of the chamber and the public
that um over the last few months i've
been put under
some quite um strange bum fluffery
with um various attempts to try and get
me
away from anything to do with finance on
moulton district council um i'm
quite saddened that um some of my fellow
independents some
of my fellow independent councillors
have been about as
slippery as a snake wearing a top at and
um i'm going to step out of this one
because uh
i this isn't going to be good for the
reputation of the council
so i'm going to be leaving this one and
i'll be putting out
what i actually think through a
different means thank you
okay thank you councilman are you
declaring an interest
good
i think you'll find he's left to meet in
chairman
yes i think that's what he was meaning
chairman he has nothing
to do okay thank you very much indeed
uh to all the other um contributors so
i'll move on then in that case
um to agenda item four strategy
uh councillor thompson you have a point
of order
thank you chairman well well i did but
it's been rather overtaken by events
and that um i really didn't think
councillor morris was making a
declaration of interest it was
more of a statement um however he was
allowed to finish so
you know cancel the point of order thank
you thank you very much
uh agenda item for strategy and
resources committee
28th of january 2021
i'm going to refer here to councillor
siddal who is chairman
of snr committee councillor siddal
thank you chairman chairman i present
the minutes
of the strategy and resources committee
meeting held remotely
on the 28th of january 2021
found on pages 7 to 126
and i propose their reception and
adoption
i'm presenting the minutes and the
recommendations contained in the
following minute numbers
i am not going to go through every
single page in turn
because there are too many
so i'm going to present the following
minute numbers with the exceptions of
minute numbers 216 to 220
as these form part of agenda item 5
the 20 21 22 budget
and medium term financial strategy due
to be considered at this meeting
so the first meeting minute is minute
221
annual review of financial regulations
recommendation page 11 that the revised
financial regulations attached at
appendix one
to these minutes be approved
could i have a sec are we are we
seconding that um council
i think say councilman
thank you carry on minute222
contract procedure rules review and
update
recommendations on page 12.
little one that the advice contract
procedure rules at appendix 2
to these minutes are approved little two
that the director of resources is
authorized to make minor changes to the
contract procedurals
minor changes are defined as follows
changes in statutory framework such as
references to new
or updated legislation
changes in titles names or terminology
changes consequential to other
constitutional changes
already made i say me could i have a
second to please
thank you councillor mace minute223
council tax support scheme 2021-22
recommendation pages 12 and 13 i see
that
councilor boyce has raised a point of
order councillor voice
i think we may have lost your audio
counselor voice
are you muted um
sorry chairman somebody must have muted
me wanted to shut me up
um i almost feel i know what council
morris feels like sometimes
um point of order i understand yes
um a point of order this is an
extraordinary
meeting of the council to discuss the
budget
and if my understanding of the
constitution is correct
that should be the only item of business
that the council is
um looking at um this
uh that um the chairman of um
strategy and resources is um bringing
out
his normal council business and should
have gone to the net
this business should have gone to the
next council meeting
i also would raise the point of the last
two items
on an extraordinary budget meeting thank
you chairman
can i have a ruling uh i'm i'm grateful
for that
and my ruling is that at my discretion
uh i'm happy to allow these
uh allow these to be um brought forward
i think in the interest of efficiency
for this council
uh councillor chana you have an
amendment to make regarding the minutes
uh yes chairman well actually yes it's
not the ones that councillor siddha's
calling out i have given notice of these
chairmen
in an email earlier today following the
guidance of uh the monitoring office who
sent an email out to all of us
and i have supplied committee services
and your good self
but the minutes that council has is
referring to leaves out totally the ones
i wanted to make amendments to
and that's um therefore confused me
chairman
so the moment i'm going through the
recommendations from those minutes
once i've gone through the
recommendations if any member wishes to
make changes to those minutes
then they can do so councillor channel
i'll leave my hand up then chairman
so i'm not forgotten thank you thank you
very much carry on councillor
thank you so much chairman say minute to
223
council tax support scheme 2021-22
recommendations page 12 and 13.
that the following changes the existing
local council tax
support scheme be approved a
a cost of living increase in line with
the apartment for work and pension
schemes
included in the local council taxes
sport scheme if i say
for 20 21 22 for pensioners only
b that any legitimacy changes being
introduced to the housing benefit scheme
for 2122 are mirrored in the council
scheme council lts scheme to ensure
consistency c the amendments to the
discussion revisions of the lcts
to ensure that the council is able to
administer the various schemes
to reflect local and national guidance d
that the lcts may reflect
any additional changes to government
wherefore benefits
regulations during the year which are
intended to
firstly increase the income of benefit
recipients
and b to introduce during a financial
year
to avoid any unintended consequences to
customers
e that this decision has been made
following members
careful reading of and regard to the
equality impact assessment attached
at appendix three to the minutes could i
have a second to please
counsellor mate councillor mace thank
you very much
minute224 policy statement
recommendation on page 13
that the pay policy statement attached
appendix 4
to the minutes be adopted for 2021.
can i have a second to please thank you
councillor mays
minute 225 insurance tender
recommendation on page 14 that the
tender process to ensure the council
has compliant insurance contracts in
place by october
2021 on the first be commenced
little two that the insurance contract
tender process
be put in place for five years with an
exception to extend the process
for the two years long-term agreement
can i have a second to please
councillor china i believe chairman has
amendments to make to the minutes
thank you councillor civil councillor
chennai yes
chairman um right if i could come in now
then if we're not going through
systematically
which as i understand the point
councillor siddal's making he didn't
wish to go through all the pages
in that case chairman can i then go to
page six
if i'm a chairman and it's disclosure of
interests
and it is regarding the first paragraph
um
there chairman um after the word it says
it says chairman in the first sentence
papers
relating to houseboats actually chairman
i think it's more uh proper to say
papers relating to the vets or these
helig
and houseboats and then it says
councillor mrs chana advised that
although in the past she had removed
herself from meeting for such items
she felt she was able to remain and
they should continue saying as things
had moved on
regarding the vessel but would not
comment should the whistles lease heli
itself be discussed i did actually give
a reason for why i felt i could remain
chairman that's that one there is
another i'll just
uh just uh hold you there are you happy
with that amendment councillor
i am happy with that amended chairman
thank you thank you carry on councillor
channel
we then come if i'm a chairman please
thank you move on to
uh minute two one nine
and if i could chairman go down to
page 10 a matter of accuracy
first regarding uh the resolve which got
resolved and then above that chairman
you can see two bullet points
in the second bullet point the
government had recently announced a
further 1.5 to be allocated
chairman that should be 15 million not
1.5 if i may
and also chairman um prior to
beneath those bullet points actually and
just before the last sentence which says
the chairman moved the recommendations
as set out in the report
and these were duly agreed by sent
actually ahead of that
chairman i i think it ought to say
councillor mrs chana indicated that she
reserved judgment until she had seen all
the budget papers at the budget meeting
prior to a senate being agreed
councillor mrs channer placed a caveat
regarding herself
on the basis that further information
may come
forward
thank you for that uh councillor siddal
are you happy with that i'm happy for
those changes
chairman okay are they able to be sent
to the clark
um council of china and then we can
include those
now i did give notice today chairman to
your good self and the clerk
thank you chen and i can confirm we have
had those thank you very much
thank you tara okay are there any other
members who wish to speak councillor
thompson
yes sorry chairman thank you um i must
apologize because i haven't notified the
clerks
um i put in i did actually mention the
same caveat as council of chana
uh with the there was strategy and
resources minute so
um if my name could possibly be included
with hers
for the same reason that would be
excellent thank you
thank you very much for that to happen
chairman
thank you casa civil uh tara are there
any other speakers
uh councillor boyce has got his hands up
chairman ah councillor boyce
um thank you chairman um i didn't want
to raise a point of order
on this but um uh
we have agreed the recommendations in
in the minutes and the alterations will
not be made tonight
but at the next meeting of the strategy
and resources
is that correct
i think it uh well i think it can be
agreed by us
as um as councillors but i don't think
we've actually agreed them as yet
because we haven't yet taken a vote
uh no i i understand that but the
chairman
had indicated that he was accepting
these changes
so the minutes will come back to snr for
the next committee meetings where they
will be reviewed and agreed there as
well
all right okay thank you for that um
councillor voice
um so are any other
people wishing to speak tara
okay no chairman no okay okay
um counselor are you happy for me to
call for the vote or would you like to
do that
i i i can call for that so i therefore
move the minutes and recommendations
with the exceptions of minutes
numbers 216 to 220 can i have a seconder
and do we agree with this please do we
agree this via a cent
or do we need a corded vote
to read
[Music]
thank you very much and we're agreeing
the amendments of council mrs chennar as
well so thank you very much
okay we will now move on to agenda item
5 the 2021-22 budget
and medium term financial strategy
and this is to receive a budget report
from the leader of the council
to consider the reports
of the section 151 officer
found on pages one two seven two three
two
six and determine the level of council
tax
for 2021 22 before i ask the leader of
the council to make her budget statement
i want to draw members attention to two
procedure rules
set out on the agenda relating to voting
and this is procedural 13 5 and budget
speech procedural
1 13 a leader please
make your budget statement thank you
thank you chairman um just before i go
on to the actual
um speech that i'm going to make i
thought i would
pay credence to last year's budget
speech that was delivered by the
previous leader
uh um only a couple of things i won't go
repeating it again but
yeah it was a very good budget and one
of the things i do wish to refer to
when councillor fluka stood up was the
recommendation or how they would look
into
meeting with the thames sailing barge
operators on a regular basis to ensure
that their needs of the council are
properly understood
so i think that was an excellent part i
think the whole budget was very good
council of luca
but i thought i would give that a
mention if you take in consideration
part of the warfight fees that we're
actually looking at tonight
so rather than steal uh councillor fluke
as thunder i will deliver my
speech i present the 21 22 budget to you
it's difficult to imagine a more
challenging time in which to prepare a
budget
however what we have achieved as a
district over the past year has been
incredible
we have come to the aid of those most
vulnerable assisting those without a
home
supporting the delivery of food of food
parcels
to those shielding and made payments to
individuals and businesses
hardest hit by the pandemic pandemic
to name but a few over 20 million pounds
of support grants were paid out to local
businesses over the year
we have also maintained the core
services throughout the pandemic and we
thank our partners including suez uh and
appleton's for continuing without
interruption despite the challenges of
covid
to collect waste and recycling from the
curbside and etching the bins around
entering the bins around our towns and
villages so thank you
in addition to the grants provided we
have worked to support businesses in
other ways
we have made changes in areas such as
the high street in malden
to create a safer shopping environment
by slowing traffic
and helping people social distance
signage
and remind earth so in german signage
and reminders
have been added to footways and outside
and out website and our website has been
adapted
to keep the public informed our parks
and open spaces
spaces have remained open with only
minor adaptations throughout
2020 allowing people to exercise safely
with their families
it hasn't only happened in mold and high
streets it's also happened in burnham
and our other villages as well so thank
you for that
the community has come together to unite
in its response
the council is leading the way in the
recovery effort
efforts recording testing and
vaccination centers
the council offices have been provided
to enable the nhs
to start vaccinating people since
december and has been a model centre
demonstrating the excellent cooperation
between the council
and the nhs the response of course has
not been without its financial costs and
although it is absolutely right that we
continue to put people before pounds
we are forecasting the 700 000 pound
overspend as a result of the
pandemic despite government's support
as we enter 21 22 it is clear that
uncertainty
will remain and we must recognize that
the inevitable
increased demand on our services there
is sufficient
financial risk in particular around our
leisure centres
car parking and events the pressures are
outlined in more detail in sections five
and seven of the budget setting report a
covert contingency fund of 371 000 has
been created for next year from the
government
from the government covert support grant
to allow a cushion for the budget
pressures
that would be faced albeit unknown
german
2021-22 has seen another one-year
settlement from central government
and as we look beyond next year the
future of the new homes bonus grant is
worth
nine hundred and thirty thousand to the
council uh will remain
have significant implications so the
medium term financial strategy
assumes the grants will go completely by
the 2023-2024
it is expected that funding will remain
in some form which will improve the
financial outlook
and i look forward to the outcome of the
government's consultation
on the future of the new new homes bonus
during the budget setting process the
cross-party financial
member working group has met on several
occasions to provide input
into the budget i'm pleased that members
have had the opportunity to work
together
and collapse collaboratively and share
their views at these and other meetings
part of the process has been ensuring
that any growth is kept to a minimum
recognizing significant financial
challenges
and unknown and unknowns ahead of us
however where it is right to invest we
have done so
this includes additional staffing to
ensure our services have the capacity to
operate
continuing with process improvement
which will be so vital in meeting future
challenges
and driving efficiencies investing
enough
in our commercial activity to bring
forward income generation and wider
benefits for the district
our local development development plan
is due for review
and the news that our housing land
supply has fallen below five years
highlights the importance of doing this
with this
in mind we have allocated one million
pounds from reserves over the next three
years to complete the vital work it is
essential that we have an up-to-date
local development development plan to
ensure that development
is appropriate housing needs are met and
then we
and that we maximize the benefits of our
community
the new plan will also reflect the
climate and environmental challenges we
face
and seek to bring forward development
that supports the aspirations of the
district
to move forward to a zero carbon future
as set out in the climate energy
statement declared by this council in
february
this year given the significant
financial pressures and need for
sustainability
we are therefore proposing that modern
district council's ban
d council taxes increase by five pounds
per annum
this equates equates to 42 pence per
month
for a vandy property this budget
provides
increased resources for our services so
they can deliver for our community
investment to bring forward commercial
aspirations and make
efficiencies a break even budget with
robust reserves for next year
and although we cannot predict what will
happen in the future
we have given ourselves a strong
foundation to respond
to all these challenges and capacity to
work to support
our community this budget meets our
fiscal responsibility and follows the
advice and
guidance of the section 151 officer as
it has in previous years mr chairman
and chairman i commend this budget to
the council
thank you thank you leader
uh 6 minutes and 15 seconds of your
15 minutes allocated time thank you uh
the leader of the opposition now has the
right
to reply counselor channel um thank you
chairman
i am sorry i don't appear to have a copy
um
of the budget speech of the leader ahead
of the the meeting
um so can i start my time now because
obviously
it would have been helpful i've made a
note at some point but i will give an
alternative and i noticed that commended
but obviously
um i haven't given my response yet
chairman so
um i do hope you bear that in mind so
therefore chairman firstly my thank the
leader
um i both started off by saying person
and i thank the leader for giving me
sight of the leaders speech on the
budget but
as i've explained that hasn't uh i
haven't got that chairman
um and i don't intend to actually um
refer or duplicate matters that the
leader has
can i just say the budget is intended to
reflect the financial requirement of the
council
and the overarching principle of
delivering first-class services to
residents and our customers
the council started this financial year
in a good financial position
as financing has always been on a
prudent financial footing with this
council no profligate spending
and has remained debt-free due to that
at the start of uh
2021-22 we move with um
good reserves in place as well chairman
likewise last year they
started off extremely healthy finances
general fund balance of over five
million
and earmarked reserves over four however
this financial year we have
like many authorities and our uh
residents and businesses experience the
unprecedented challenging time of kobe
19
consequently the financial year has been
seen higher expenditure than normal
due to it essentially unprecedented
emergency response from the council
however the government has given support
and reliefs throughout the year
in funding terms at this juncture i have
to mention the kovid 19 unprecedented
times
and i want to thank all the council
officers for their unstinting commitment
dedication and professional application
while working in difficult circumstances
they have worked round the clock to
ensure that services and support to our
residents
has been largely maintained and the same
quality level applied
innovation has been uh forthcoming
and in partnership with others has
assisted a holistic response to the
pandemic
returning to the exp um expenditure the
pandemic the council has uh lost income
for instance from car parks events
splash park
beach huts etcetera in the past
financial year and going into 2021 like
the leader said the impact of corona
coronavirus is difficult to predict as
there is still uncertainty
however the roadmap released by the
government does albeit with quite
rightly caution
give hope on the horizon however the
government has promised to extend the
income compensation scheme for the first
quarter
and it may be further support is
provided that is an unknown at the
moment but
more may be revealed in march for 2021
22 the local government finance
settlement for malden which is a
favorable settlement
close is actually chairman the budget
gap and we have a number of girls which
the leader referred to
new homes burners rural services grant
local council support grant and the
lower tier services grant together with
comed 19 funding of 319 thousands forms
from the government forms our covet
contingency budget
granting come along with fees and
charges and business rates can
collection is the three main sources of
income
for us there are budget pressures as the
leader referred to
and this uh includes um assumed
decreasing collection of both
uh council tax and business uh rates and
repairs and renewals capital expenditure
local development plan external audit
planning enforcement
and election costs growth includes a
local plan review local development
scheme
digitalization project service delivery
staffing
and process implementation staff and
systems improvement
growth is totally one million and ninety
four thousand for the twenty one twenty
two year
i think bearing in mind the number of
new staff positions the council need to
be mindful of staff creep
and associated costs bearing in mind the
transformation process undertaken
and the designed operating model i
appreciate the budget seats for a five
pound increase on council tax
the maximum possible however i have
referred to kobit 19 more than once the
pressures the council has been
under however our residents have also
been under pressure
under stress many have lost family and
friends through covid
they have been suffering community
suffering after strategic resources
uh the employment rate for malden came
out and increased significantly
unemployment nationally is the highest
for 30 years
many in our district have been
furloughed lost jobs businesses
once successful have not weathered the
storm our residents are suffering
kobit 19 has affected lives in
immeasurable ways
the number of vulnerable families has
increased and we know now the council
tax precepts resist county council and
the police
and if we were to add our five pound
maximum chairman
we are going to add to the burden and it
will make it
for budgets residence budgets of 34
pounds 70 per annum
and that is before the respective parish
precept is applied
it is time now for this council to stand
up for our residents
it is time for this council to play our
part in helping ease the financial
pressures stress suffering of our
residents maximum
of five pounds is 2.47 increase in
council tax
three and a half times the rate of
inflation at these times it is not a
route the authority should follow
for this coming financial year in
support of all our residents our
customers
council tax should be frozen my uh
preference for upsetting the 125 000 and
the 2.4 percent increase would bring
is regarding the barges warfight fees
which has changed actually from
six uh mentioned at uh stretching
resources to eight
and uh i do support that therefore to
offset that
fourteen thousand which won't be
collected we use from the business
equalization reserve chairman
further increasing green waste by one
pound 49 pound year
the charges remained at 46 for the last
two years
there is a growing demand it is a
service residents determined to join
it is choice pre-application fees to
rise by 1.5 percent
not just the cpi of 0.7 because there's
a staff pay rise that may be coming in
of 1.5
and it's only right chairman that the
opposite time in pre-application
meetings
should be covered by those requiring the
service
assumed reduction in audit fee growth
due to negotiation
of ten thousand pounds also the
government having
indicated uh 50 million will be provided
to court councils regarding the extra
audit charge
and also any work undertaken by la's the
relevant report tonight now includes
reference to this
and assumes twelve thousand pounds if
based on population
although it may be more being reasonable
chairman i promote
ten thousand from the monies coming from
the government can be utilized to help
offset 125
000 funding of both the one-year post in
the budget of the parks and countryside
officer
and part of the commercial manager cost
of um
27 050 000 respectively to come from
um the use of transformation reserves
also chairman in respect of um
uh i've lost my plan now transparent
reserves also chairman
i think all those together i think i
mentioned the whole lot i'll just check
i've mentioned assume audit fees uh
funding from the government regarding
authentic fees the regiment reviews 10
000 pounds to come off uh further
increasing green waste i've mentioned
increasing pre-app charge increased use
of business rate secularization
reserve to offset actually the reduction
in warface fees funding of parks and
countryside officer from transformation
reserve
park funding of commercial manager post
growth from the transformation reserve
all those things i've mentioned chairman
do actually total 125
000 so there need be no council tax
increase
no impact also chairman on the general
fund balance
and additionally officers be tasked or
asked with identifying savings in 2020
22
to reduce the required drawdown from
earmarked reserves
this is a budget uh proposal that i feel
my sort of preference would be to reduce
the stress and strains and the impacts
on our residents
as they are suffering at this time
chairman thank you
and now just ask a matter of procedure
chairman
yes shut up sorry does someone say
something
no yes council channel go ahead
all right i've given that chairman um
can you just explain the procedure
uh well first of all we have um a right
of reply
by the leader um you have five minutes
later
chairman i think council boyce has got
his hand up would you like to speak
before i do my right of reply is that
allowed
i i certainly would um yes i'm sorry i
see that yeah cancel the voice go ahead
um i
uh second um uh council mrs chana's
uh proposal and as the leaders
um uh proposal
has not been seconded therefore mrs
tanner's becomes the substantive motion
i didn't think cancer china proposed
anything i thought yes she did
i quite distinctly heard her well
i i think we need clarity from the the
clerk
and there is a process in the procedure
which is absolutely fine
um and uh yes i i would like to come
back but i'll wait until
um it's been sorted out thank you yes i
i think that that was a response to
the uh to the leader's speech
uh i didn't take it as a proposal
chairman i think i did use the word
proposal towards the end and said
yes i didn't use the final proposal so
it interrupted it wasn't as as i
understand a formal proposal i think
sorry i don't agree with that can we
have clarity from the officers
rather than the members please chair
yes uh mr crouch can you assist
i can listening to um the opposition
leader i didn't
i didn't take it as a proposal uh formal
proposal
right okay thank you so we have the
first proposal by councillor stamp and i
ask for a seconder
chairman may i come in here uh chairman
if you don't mind
no i think i actually think it's my
right to reply first well it's a point
of order
chairman i was going to be making now
what is the point of order counselor
channel
well i thought chairman what was
happening was we would go through this
process
and then my understanding was
the the the budget papers um because i
have our asked officers about this the
budget papers
would be moved on mass and my amendment
could be applied yeah yeah chairman
she's cut cats of china is quite right
but i haven't got to that stage yet the
process is
i make my speech the leader of the
opposition makes their speech
i have a right to reply and then i do
that and then
the uh the amendments can be made that
is my understanding
and if that's incorrect i think mr
quelch needs to come in
and actually tell me i'm incorrect thank
you jim
mr crouch chairman that that's my
understanding looking at
the rule one it says
there's a leader's speech on the budget
then there's a response now
that response as i understand it is
purely to the leader's speech
it's not at that particular point there
is that there is any debate
um and then there is before it goes into
debate which is where a proposal will be
put
forward the leader has a reply that's my
understanding of it
immediately the leader has given her
reply
then it becomes debate and plainly
chairman you can take proposals from
anybody
um on on any matter in relation to the
budget
yes thank you very much and uh i think i
can see my notes that
that there will be that there will be a
proposal so
in order to do this procedurally
correctly
um counselor channel you've had the
right of reply
and i'm now going back to the leader for
their response
uh thank you chairman um i'm not going
to go into a great deal of response
counselor chana
um stated her her response to my
very eloquently it's all in the pack uh
what councillor channel actually
uh said was uh um factually correct
uh and if members have actually i'm sure
they've all read the 252 pages
whatever it is of this uh budget meeting
uh it all states quite clearly in there
i was really focusing on that we had
tried to work together on this which is
absolutely fine but that's
i don't mind but i would like members to
be aware
and i um in and i'm going to say this
chairman i hope i'm i'm going to be okay
mr quelch please stand in if you think
i'm going too far
2015 2016 which was an election year
the percent and don't forget the way
that the way that this
council has been um governed by the
political leadership
it went down to 1.5 and it was 2.64
in 2016-17 it gradually started going up
one point oh here's my point of order
i'll stop now
point of order counselor voice um
chairman
um i don't wish to dispute with you
or the leader the process but
the leader's speech when she says
i commend this budget to the council
which she said
is actually the budget proposal which is
normally seconded that has
always been how this matter has been
conducted
now the other issue is the leader's
response uh should come
at the uh the completion of the
debate and so to allow
members to raise issues or questions
about the budget
all right i'm grateful for that but what
what we have is
the leaders speech the leader of the
opposition's response and now we're
returning back to the leader
for their response that's how i'd like
to run it thank you
leader okay so thank you for that uh mr
chair
um so 2016-17 it gradually
went up to 1.95 2017-18 went up to 2.75
2018 2019 went up to 2.99
and then at the election election year
again 2.
in 2019-20 it went down and then it went
up again to 2.53 percent in 2021
and now in 2122 it's going up to 2.47
so it's actually reduced and so i i'm
not going to get into a bit of dispute
mr chairman
but you know we can all play political
games it is serious we are undercoved
and i think it's really really important
that we agreed this budget
and the procedure that i have been
informed by the monitoring officer
is now that i propose that my
speech and the budget is agreed
on block and chairman it is my
understanding that you will also
go through the procedural procedural
rule after i put the proce
the budget for approval and get it
seconded
mr quelch can i have um can i have that
agreed before i move on in case i have
made an
error thank you chairman jim and that's
my understanding that's correct
my understanding is that right okay so i
called for this
please councillor mays council amaze
that is
thank you very much thank you
so i've actually asked it to go on block
um mr chairman and i
i think i have an amendment
but it now gets open to debate doesn't
it
i have an amendment he's now open to
every councillor
i have an amendment chairman and i'm
taking it i can make my amendment now
that's as i understand it
uh i think that um that's what i
understood from the officers
well i i have a note here at uh that if
uh
i think that is correct chairman um as
we've now entered into debate
there is a proposal on the table it's
been seconded
i think chairman my understanding of the
rules would be subject to what you say
your ruling is that mrs chandler can now
make an amendment
right okay what is your what is it what
is your amendment then
uh councillor channel well thank you
chairman just before i make that in
relation to what the leader said about
the previous council tax increases
i can explain those chairmen they were
actually in line
um with inflation um you will find
ordinarily the council tax over the few
the few years the leader is referring to
i think you'll find you'll find a
correlation with the inflation rates at
the time
obviously now with covid uh the
inflation rate
of cpi which we based our budget has
gone down to 9.7
right here
i thought i'd just answer that um my
amendment chairman is that really
which i said at the end of my speech
pointing out
that point of older place point of order
chairman i don't normally often make a
point of order but i
um there was no right of reply that i
was told that council china to give a
right of reply to what i'd said
if tanzania wishes to make an amendment
that is councillor china's right but she
had no right to reply
to my reply thank you i think chairman
under um
rule 1 council
can you give your amendment chairman can
i just say
rule 13 rule 113b
i know 13a does say about both of us i
think response is there too to our
speeches
i'm pretty sure both of us can so i'm
sure the monitoring officers will tell
me if i'm correct incorrect my amendment
chairman
is that the council tax for this year
be frozen at naught percent and the way
i can remove the 125
000 pounds at the 2.47 increase
um taking the five pound maximum to
councils
would be ten thousand pounds assumed
reduction in audit fees growth due to
negotiations
ten thousand funding from government for
audit increase render
redmond review because we get um some
money income from that
thirteen thousand further increase in
greece waste collections by one pound to
forty nine pounds a year
one one thousand might seem a small
amount but we're likely to have
increases in pre-applications
due to our housing uh land supply
situation increased pre-apps charges by
1.5 percent
in line with what officers may be
getting in this financial uh in the next
financial year
14 000 increased use of business rates
equalization reserve
to offset the reduction in mortgage fees
which covers the eight barges which is
the new figure applied in the papers
because the papers at budget setting
have got changes in that are different
to the
strategy and resources the pre strategy
resources based
on only six parties chairman um and then
uh 27 000 funding of parks and
countryside
office of post for transformation
reserve
heart funding 50 000 of the commercial
manager post growth from the
transformation reserve
the sub total chairman comes to 125
000 there's no increase in council tax
uh total impact on the general fund
chairman
um is is not um affected at all
and additional the officers um look
obviously to achieve savings to offset
some of the trans uh some of the
reserves chen which is good
funding so a naughty council tax
chairman with those amendments
um and will apply to the documents
chairman
appropriately thank you
councillor councillor
chairman councillor bell has had a hand
up since i started speaking
chairman i'm sorry i i can't see that on
my screen counselor
thank you councillor bell thank you
um members can we just get some
perspective please
five pounds a month that's two happy
meals
two mcdonald's happy meals five pounds a
month
60 pounds a year really do you really
think that residents would object to
paying that much
that little for having services
for all the support that we intend to
give them instead of having
things cut to the bone again five pounds
a month it's not even it's not a cinema
trip once a month it's just it's it's
it's
in sorry it's just it's nothing i can't
believe that we're actually quibbling
over five pounds a month members i
really can't
thank you thank you councillor
councilworld councillor durham you're
next
yeah thank you chairman i'm gonna try
and be helpful i think
in terms of procedure i think you'll
find that um
now that there's been an amendment to
the leaders um
motion uh that will be voted on first if
that falls it will then
uh go back to um the substantive motion
that is the leaders however if the
amendment yeah if the amendment is
passed
that then becomes the substantive motion
and we'll take a vote on it but i have
actually have a question
for for the leader um please leader you
mentioned in
your speech that you were going to be
relying on funding from the new homes
bonus
i'm just wondering whether you have
worked in a contingency bearing in mind
that the new homes bonus
is currently under consultation this
consul government consultation ends
um at the end of april uh
legacy payments will be ceased and there
is uh
obviously a chance that the new homes
bonus payments
may also significantly change so i'm
just slightly concerned
that we're putting all our eggs in the
new homes bonus basket
when the goal posts may well get moved
after the consultation is considered
and the government white paper is
produced thank you
uh thank you um councillor durham it's
an excellent question
um christopher leslie chris leslie's
also mentioned this so i'm going to
we've had a conversation about this
so i'm going to go directly to him
because it was discussed
at great length this uh because i'm not
sure what the update is if there was
if there has been an update mr leslie
can you jump in here because i know
we have talked about this yeah
absolutely um
so the allocations for next year for the
new homes bonus they've been confirmed
the consultation uh will look to
subsequent years
so next year um in the budget that's
obviously been allocated
and from future early years we're only
assuming a very small
legacy payment i'm appreciating that
obviously that may change over the
consultation but it is very small i
think 198
000 down from the 930 000 pounds
and then ceasing completely uh in the
final year
so we are assuming a very um big
decrease coming from a new home's bonus
and then going completely
in three years time so we're hoping that
the consultation will actually provide
better news and improve the funding
situation so i hope that provides some
reassurance to members
thank you and we'll keep our fingers
firmly crossed then thank you
thank you mr leslie thank you thank you
um
just yeah chairman for forgive me to to
with your permission
um uh councillor chana's
proposed amendment hasn't yet been
seconded so for there to be a debate on
that
second indeed okay so what i'm going to
do is
i i'm taking the first uh
i'm taking the leaders proposal
first that has been seconded i'm now
opening this chairman that's not that
isn't correct procedure i'm sorry you
have to take an amendment first
and if that amendment fails then you
that that is the if if that if the
amendment passes that then becomes a
substantive
yes you have to take an amendment before
the substantive
chairman that is correct
could i ask you all to stop speaking
orders
can you help me out here please yes i
can chairman um
what counselor durham said is that
absolutely correct the procedure
is as follows the leader put forward a
proposal
to accept the budget um that was
seconded
so that became the substantive motion
counselor channel then had the right to
make an amendment
to that original motion uh
that was julie seconded by mrs thompson
there now has to be a debate and a vote
taken on whether that amendment
changes the original motion
if that vote is carried then that that
amendment
takes the place of the original motion
and the
debate continues on it i see and if it
fails we'll go back to the original
correct if it fails then the original
motion
remains the same yes yeah right thank
you very much
point of order please mr uh and i call
on mr quelch here my understanding is
um yes the amendment we have the debate
on that and take the vote on that first
but also my understanding is another
amendment can be removed
if that should fail chairman it doesn't
just have to totally flip black
to um the um leaders proposal i think
there can be more amendments that's my
understanding from officers
uh chairman if i may just assist there
that's absolutely right
if mrs chana's amendment seconded by
um counselor mrs thompson fails
on a vote then another person may put
forward
another amendment to the original motion
and again
that needs to be seconded and again
there can be debate on that a vote taken
to see if that succeeds in changing the
original motion
all right okay thank you very much i'm
going to move next to councillor siddall
thank you chairman uh i was i'm quite
disappointed with some of the behavior
that's occurring this evening
and i thought the whole point that would
be in terms of the way that we were
operating at this council was
about cooperation and working together
and
i'd like to see a little bit more of
that in terms of what counselor channel
has said in terms of
the money that she's finding for these
uh savings and using the money a
different way
one interesting thing is that council
channel talks about the transformation
reserve
in january this year as part of
strategic resources as part of that
committee
we've decided to write off 125 000
that hasn't been found in terms of
savings
from the transformation so it's
interesting now that councillor chana's
actually trying to find 250 000 pounds
she also stated thank you councillor
chennai
let me finish please i she's also stated
that last
year the amount of money
that we pay for green recycling
hasn't increased it did increase it
increased for those
uh people that previously were paying by
direct debit
their discount in terms of direct debit
was removed
so that was increased last year also
in terms of the amount of money that was
and i was in the conservative group at
the time
the amount of money that we did increase
the council tax by last year was above
inflation so again that is incorrect
in terms of the budget in terms of these
proposals that have been put forward by
the leader
and by the administ independent
administration
it we have been extremely cautious and
made sure that we are being prudent in
the way that we spend
the council taxpayers money we can't be
more prudent
i remember councillor durham saying at
the joint standards committee meeting
that he'd never seen a budget where
there was so little capital expenditure
so councillor durham has commended our
prudence
in terms of this budget we can't be more
prudent than we've have been
and that's the crucial thing in terms of
this it's interesting
and i noticed today on facebook that
this was posted quite strongly
that braintree district council has
promoted
in terms of this election year that
they're not increasing the council tax
and i really see what pac councillors
channel is doing
is politically motivated rather than
what's best
for malden district council thank you
chairman
thank you councillor councillor yes
thank you chair it's just a very minor
thing
um as councillor channel said in the
report about warfare it was about eight
barges
i have spoken to the officers and the
fact is that's an incorrect
uh statement it is actually six because
they're talking about an aspiration to
to bring two who have not been on the
key back so it's not 14 000
it's it's significantly less than that
they're very small but just as important
if we're going through things with a
laser lamp
thank you chair thank you councillor
swan
um council channel has
quite properly put forward
an amazing amendment which would have
the effect of freezing
council tax that's fair enough
but all that she's then gone on to try
and find some way
of looking at every item in the budget
isn't isn't um uh isn't justified
uh she can't present it as an
alternative budget
she can simply put forward the proposal
to freeze
council tax i don't think all the other
things that she said which is
speculative and um
detail about how she would prepare an
alternative budget
is can't be part of the actual amendment
all right thank you councillor jarvis
thank you chairman um i've listened with
interest to what council channel has
said with regards to the leader's
budget proposal but one of the points i
know that she did mention
was one of the savings will be some
progress with regards to negotiation on
audit fees
um i'd really uh counter that i mean you
should never
build in an assumption that your
negotiations are going to be successful
so i think it would be very it wouldn't
be very prudent at all
to build that into a budget i mean there
are some negotiations on audit fees
and obviously those are taking place but
considering
some advantage we will taking into
account now that some advantage
will be gained would be most important
um i
think the budget which has been tabled
has been very carefully
thought through i think in fact uh
it's quite clear if you look at a number
of the tables in the budget
um that we're only over the next few
years we are going to struggle as a
council
once uh the government grants ease off
there is some
overspending uh is likely to occur and
the reserves are likely to be
uh under threat so we will have to make
some changes
but all of those changes i think we'll
be you know sort of looking at the
expenses seeing where we can trim
and seeing what additional income we can
get i mean my point is really that
you know to try and uh put forward as
councillor chana is proposing
a budget which doesn't have an increase
on council tax is very naive because
i think we're going to need that uh at
least
and i think the issues are really going
to be in three
in three years time what changes we can
build in
to the way the council you know is run
to ensure that we've controlled uh
expenses and reserves in a few years so
i question some of the uh
items that council china has raised i
think it will be improved
um to to assume those savings thank you
chairman
thank you councillor durham i don't
think have you spoken on this
yet yeah i just wanted to come back very
quickly
on i'm just a point and and councillor
said it was absolutely correct and i did
commend
uh snr uh for their very prudent um
capital
reduction but of course the majority of
the which is quite true and
and necessarily so but of course most of
this budget refers to revenue spending
so
um it's not really the point and and
indeed
um a braintree district council uh who
have made quite a big deal in fact of
freezing their council tax as have
epping and a couple of others
uh they're not actually subject to
elections so um
that's just just to clarify that point
thank you
councillor channel you've already spoken
on this council thompson
oh thank you chairman um i just wanted
to say when
those of us um in the conservative group
saw the budget
presented at s um we did feel it was
reasonable and prudent but we did put in
the caveat that we wanted to see
you know what other news came forward in
the meantime and as councillor chana
said we have got
the unemployment figures and the other
things and you know
times are hard things are very very
different this time last year when we
were setting the budget then
um and i fully support her move to try
and
give the residents of the district a bit
of a break on the
council tax i think that's very laudable
thank you
thank you councillor boyce
thank you chairman um i'm i'm all at sea
i don't know whether we're debating the
amendment
or the leader's proposal or whether
we're taking the debate
uh um the whole debate um together
um but i have a question
um for the leader but i just wish to
commend mrs chana um
for thinking that the residents of this
district and not
the socialist uh wish to push up council
tax as much as possible
um i think the question i have for the
question i have
um for the leader relates to the
question i asked her
at the last council meeting on car parks
now car parking it comes under
i think uh of um mr seattle's
uh council settles uh committee of uh
minute two one six of fees and
and charges and um
this council resolved many years ago to
allow
electric vehicles to have free car
parking
which was a question i asked of to be
researched
nobody has come back to me i would have
thought that the budget time that was
the most appropriate
uh time for this for this to
come up under the fees and charges
and the question to the leader is have
you made
any contingencies for this resolution
which i'm assuming hasn't been
researched yet or
officers haven't been able to find the
resolution
but it's there somewhere yeah thank you
council voice again uh what i what i
don't want
uh to happen is for this meeting
uh to start uh being reduced to name
calling so
references to socialism uh conservative
or anything else like that
i want to keep it please um
setting the budget is very political
you're
very naive if you don't think it is well
i don't
uh i don't like the idea of you
referring to anybody
uh is in any particular way counselor
voice so
i think we need to keep this
professional i'm sure you'll agree
councillor stem
thank you chair um councillor boyce did
raise it was a very good point last time
and he'll be assured to know that we are
going to look at it as part of the
climate strategy
regarding the car parking it's in the
bigger picture and
we need to actually think it through
though and to be part of the strategic
approach councillor boyce
as i'm sure you'll agree um chairman can
i just actually
say here we we this budget needs to be
sustainable
and if we start to not increase the uh
preset
it puts pressures on as in future years
it's short-termism
uh mr mr chairman the reserves will be
below
uh in a minimum of three years it's not
building it
any capacity for covid the leisure
contract could be worse
and it's going to give it it could give
us a financial impact
i thought the budget was was good and i
thought it was prudent and i think the
section 151 officer
has actually done an astounding job to
keep his fingers
on on the um purse strings councillor
siddall
did actually make some excellent points
and because we all know at these
meetings mr chairman
and this is why i'm a little bit
surprised that we're going into so much
detail which is absolutely fine because
it's an excellent debate
these have been discussed before and
some of these uh
agreements and amendments have already
been um policies have been agreed
yeah previously so you know thank you
for allowing me to say
speak again uh chairman but we do need
to look at the bigger picture
it can't be short-termism um you know
and it
is an election year let's not let's not
be um
naive using the word that seems to be
banded about at the moment thank you mr
chair
thank you very much what i'm going to do
now is i'm going to i think this has
been
well debated and i'm going to move to
the vote and the vote
is i've have that for some time and i
haven't been allowed to speak yet
i'm i'm sorry councillor i i i haven't
seen your hand i will let you speak as
you haven't spoken
before um thanks
thank you uh mr chairman to my video but
since
thank you mr chairman um just briefly um
we um
as a group spoke to the section 151
officer and
he indeed did find our um budget
proposal to be
sound um so i i take a little bit of
umbrage
with it being said that the um budget
that we proposed wasn't sound
and i'd also like to say that for
many of my residents who've contacted me
a lot of people for the first time in
their lives are struggling they've got
lost jobs they're on furlough
and at the moment they don't have 5p to
spare
and i just think this is not the time to
put
any raise on council tax at all we are
here
to support our residents and for me
that's the most important reason for us
being here
is to look after our residents in these
times these are not
normal times we have to be as mindful as
we can
and as i say our budget stacks up the
one five one officer has
it sustainable let's try and look after
the residents in our district
some of whom are struggling for the
first time in their lives
because they've got problems with their
income so that that that's why i think
our budget is still able to
look after our residents okay thank you
councillor white
councillor fluco you haven't spoken yet
sorry chairman i seem to have lost my
hand i presume you can all hear me
um chairman i mean every single
household and business in the district
is being affected by the pandemic
and these are extraordinary times um
the budget provides an opportunity for
the council to show some
empathy to its residents and businesses
it's not been mentioned yet
clearly but it is and i've always been a
great advocate of this
and that is to protect the tax base for
future years
but we do have reserves they're not our
reserves they're the residence
reserves and in extraordinary times we
should look towards using those
and that said german i find it
unacceptable that we're proposing to
increase the tax
this year because our residents have
suffered so much
and in my mind to use the additional tax
rates to support a reduction in fees for
a small number of businesses
is is an affront to all the other
businesses who've worked so incredibly
hard to keep going during this pandemic
chairman fiscal issues aside this budget
lacks
innovation empathy and compassion and
that said
i cannot support it and for families
that are struggling to pay for school
meals
and believe me they are a lot and
members will remember the regeneration
report um that and they don't receive
support five pound is a lot of money
and this rise is going to affect people
who five pounds a lot of money do
chairman
in my mind we can we can discuss this
all evening but at the end of the day
it will be our residents who have the
final say as to whether they support
this budget or not
and they will have some of them will
have their final say
in may so i would propose chairman that
we
go to the vote and obviously as a budget
vote it will be recorded
and and chairman thank you for coming in
because i don't know where it's gone but
i've lost my hand
thank you thank you councilman [ __ ]
okay
um mr leslie do we have um council of
uh proposals
yes thank you chairman uh i'll put them
on the screen if that's all right and if
it's okay with yourself chairman just
very briefly run through it if that's
okay
yes please so every cell members are
clear
[Music]
you let the leader come back in
yes i'll come to you against the channel
thank you
chairman just can i uh qualify something
uh councillor lagan
um more or less had you spoken about
officers and about the eight barges and
that wasn't the case or more or less
words that affect
i can tell you on the budget report
tonight um fees and charges
and i think that might be c i can tell
you that's exactly where i got the eight
barges from and it says under a certain
paragraph in the report 3.7
of particular note are the warfighter
fees which have been recommended
to be reduced by 50 percent and it gives
the figures from the annual warfare fees
and it gives the figure of 14 300 based
on
eight barges chairman strategy and
resources
it was only six and i have checked this
out with the 151 officer
and as you know chairman i have to give
details of the budget
three days um clear days in advance of
this budget meeting
and i was asked to give details of where
i would get the
the funding from or i think and i can
tell you
that if this has not been deemed
reasonable i would not be presenting it
tonight because obviously you go through
to check it's legal and
reasonable and counsellor jarvis
referred to me being
um again i think about income and the
audit charges
um actually a great deal of caution's
been put on those figures and let's say
50 000 the doubling of the audit fees
we've all expressed alarm at that
and therefore the 10 000 through
negotiation
has been deemed to be reasonable not
just something out my hat but in a
conversation
thank you can we just have mr leslie
give this uh
give this uh uh budget then that this
alternative budget that we're we're
going to vote on this amendment
mr leslie thank you chairman so we have
um
ten thousand pounds uh assumed reduction
in
audit fees um due to negotiation
uh so that's a reduction in expenditure
time uh we have 10 000
as well for additional funding from the
grant given for the pressures on audit
as well as part of the um allocation
announced but we don't have individual
breakdown yet
of what that might be for us uh as a
council
we have a thirteen thousand pounds
additional income
from the green waste by increasing that
we have an increase of a thousand in
terms of the pre-apps
by increasing that to 1.5 percent
we also have 14 000 coming out of the
business rate equalization
reserve we also have
27 000 coming from the transformation
reserve
to fund the countryside officer post
and also 50 000
coming from transformation reserve as
well
to fund the commercial manager post
providing 125 000
amount there and also that will offset
the council tax increase
there to provide a freeze and if i may
um
chairman i'd just like to show
as well the balances
uh from that in terms of the apologies
for the uh
the remote uh screen sharing but in
terms of the
[Music]
number again there we go thank you in
terms of the general fund uh impact
um as well so there's a table um coming
forward there
in terms of the amendments for next year
obviously no impact
and then obviously as we move to 22 23
um
there's a assumption that obviously we
wouldn't continue to use
the um earmarked reserve to fund that
so that would have to then add to the
gap which would then look to be
addressed by other sources and just for
completeness
as well in terms of the year mark
reserve sorry a lot of figures here but
essentially the ones
that i think are key here i'm trying to
highlight
they're the business rates equalization
reserve so that's the 14 000 coming from
that
providing um a balance there and the
alternative budget
and the same for the transformation 77
000 out there
obviously having an impact um there just
so members can see the
impact on the reserves and the general
fund balance
right thank you very much so we have uh
we have this uh
amendment which has been duly seconded
by mrs
uh by councillor thompson uh i'm going
to take that to the vote
now tara are you able to take the vote
please
uh yes chairman of course so remember
this is a vote on the alternative
proposal as being made by councillor mrs
channel
and if you could indicate fought against
your abstain please when i call your
name
starting with councillor bassinger
please
so refuse okay thank you very much
cancer miss bill
thank you councillor brian bill against
you councillor bell against thank you
councillor boyce
for thank you council mrs channel
four thank you councillor durham
thank you very much that's for
councillor edwards
against the councilman
four thank you council fluker
four thank you councillor heard
abstain you cancer helm
four you counselor hull
ball you counselor jarvis
against you counselor keys
four key counseling lagging
against that's the maze
against thank you cancer against
ki cast the schemes against
cancer stamp the gate that's the stilts
against swain
okay this is thompson
four thank you council miss white
four the results of that chairman are
12 4 14 against and one abstention thank
you very much
thank you that has failed then uh
in in that case i will return to the
leaders proposal
councillor thompson you've got your hand
up uh i have thank you chairman um
i wish to make a further amendment um i
suspect it will go the same way
um but i would like to put it anyway
that we keep the naught percent uh
council tax um as that part of
councillor channel's amendment
uh however we take it all from the
business equalization fund
and this has actually been cleared as a
sensible proposal with the one part one
officer
so i moved that amendment would uh
someone please second me
i'll second that thank you
chairman can i ask that councillor
durham turns his screen off
unfortunately meeting his dinner
i'm finding it a little bit distracting
get together i'll finish
i've i've just finished leader i do
apologize thank you apricots and cream
i'm sorry
right we have that further we have that
further amendment
uh does anybody wish to further comment
on that counselor fluker
[Music]
i see you have your hand up it's gone
down now
hang on hang on sorry sorry sorry um
right okay so okay that remember my
counselor thompson i think is
very very interesting and it seems to me
as though we're moving to a status quo
on this but i think before we consider
it i would like to hear
what the 151 has to say about the
implications
of voting in favor of what i consider
is a very very good amendment for the
benefit
of the residents of malden district
thank you
mr leslie
thank you jim so the amendment centers
around the use
of the business equalization reserve and
earmarked reserve
for 125 000 pounds uh there is money in
that reserve
uh for next year members will obviously
want to consider the implications of
future years as well
earmarked reserves being only a one-off
source of funding and not a recurring
source
so in future years you have to have to
consider the implications
of how that money is funded in future
years for next year
reserves remain above the minimum at 2.7
2.6 million
in terms of the general fund for that
side
so they would remain above that level
for next year
and then was going to have a forecast in
terms of the future
uh implications for that and how that
may be addressed going forward
thank you um i have another hand
appeared i'm not sure whose it is yet
tara
chairman that's councillor siddal thank
you answer siddle
you're muted counselor siddle
so in terms of these things uh as the
count as the
section 151 officers just said all it's
doing is kicking the can
down the road it's about delaying it
this year
for political reasons and delaying the
consequences for residents
in the future and i'll say for this
council
the section y five one officer has just
said
that if we to make these decisions the
impact on the reserves
in future years would have serious
implications
because it is not budgeted so therefore
what we are doing as an administration
now is prudent
and cautious and best for residents and
best
for the council
okay i'm only going to take questions
and
comments on the amendment now so i'll go
to
counselor jarvis
thank you chairman i mean i think
there's i think my point is really about
the reserves i know i
already made this earlier on but it you
know the reserves basically run out more
or less in
in two or three years time if you
project through a number of the charts
which appear
throughout the uh the budget document i
mean
we will need um some serious changes so
with that
horizon if people can think more than
just the immediate year
with that horizon of two or three years
we should do everything we can
to ensure we protect the reserves so
using the reserves
uh when you when you don't have to of
course it's a difficult decision of
course we all want to do
the best thing we can for residents i
think the budget as it's proposed
does that if we take more than a very
short-term view
which is what i think some councils are
putting on the table thank you jen
thank you councillor jarvis um
councillor white
on this amendment only please
thank you uh mr chairman my video won't
hurt itself back on the game
um i'd just like to say that with this
amendment um as i said before
this is not short-sighted nobody could
have foreseen the coronavirus
um sort of taking effect in the
countryside
or country and or the world and people
are really really struggling and and
i'm not involved in the elections this
year makes a difference to me
all i'm bothered about the other
residents in my ward and in this
district we have to look after the ones
who are struggling
not just the ones who are okay at the
moment thank you
thank you councillor chana on the
amendment please
thank you chairman i'm trying to take my
um hand down actually
um yes well i think of course i would
say this i know i'm going to save
other people from hamming to say that
but i think it is a very sensible
amendment
and i'm sorry uh councillor civil you
may say political
but actually um councillor white gave a
very good
summary and it is about residents a lot
of people are hurting
and actually we know the spending review
the settlement we've got is one year
um we've got the um the road map now
coming
and actually if you look at what they're
doing
it does say we're going to see increases
i would really like you to speak
on the american amendment chairman it is
it's tied up because
other people have mentioned other things
and therefore we know the
rate of inflation will go up and we will
see improvements coming so we
we have to bear in mind the settlement
that was given for one year
and next year i think we will be in a
different position to where we are today
kobed has influenced a lot all right
thank you councillor helm
thank you very much mr chairman um i
know
counselor java said we shouldn't use
reserves but the people we represent
have all used their reserves all the
businesses have used their reserves
they're right down to their last penny
and five pound will make a lot of
difference
thank you thank you uh i'm going to go
now to the vote
on this amendment um
tara could you do the roll call again
please
uh yes chairman of course so members
this is voting um
on the amendment as proposed by council
mrs thompson
and if you could indicate as before
fought against rob stein please
just ask has that been seconded tara yes
it was second dead chairman
thank you i didn't know that thank you
[Music]
so starting with um councillor bassinger
please
against thank you councillor miss phil
thank you council brian beale against
thank you cancer bell against
you boys poor
thank you council mrs channel four
four thank you character darren
councillor edwards
again thank you councillor mrs fleming
for thank you councillor fluker
for cats to
[Music]
against council morley
four thank you councillor none
against councillor shawnee
against cancer
against
[Music]
that's a stamp against
the stilts against that's the swing
against castle mrs thompson
paul and council miss white
um for tara thank you thank you members
chairman the results of that are 12
4 14 against and one abstention
thank you very much thank you that has
failed then in that case
i will return to the leaders
proposal and that
leader did you want to take this did you
want to um
propose these on block yes i did say
that originally so i'll do it again if
you wish
mr chairman i i would like to propose on
block it is all um listed there at
german
um so i would like to a proposed unblock
the recommendation
set out in the budget reports 5a to 5f
as detailed
uh in in the report chairman or mr welch
mr coach do i need to go through
a b c and read out capital investment
strategies do i need to go through
everything um mr
quelch please or do you think the
members would allow me don't think so
they're already there in the report
they're in front
thank you cancer channel for actually
agreeing to that i saw you nodding so
i think they met the proposals quite
clear
can i have a second day please
thank you and thank you members so we
don't have to read them all out
that is what i propose and it's second
did chairman so can i ask for the vote
please
thank you thank you i'll now uh
go to the vote tara
thank you chairman thank you members uh
so voting
uh as the leader just said for the
proposals 5825s
if as set out in the reports if you
could indicate four against or abstain
please starting with councillor
bassinger please
thank you councilman against
brian bill thank you
casabelle four thank you councillor
boyce
against thank you so much
against thank you councillor durham
against thank you council durham
councillor edwards
four thank you councilman fleming
against thank you council fluker against
thank you councillor heard abstain
thank you councillor helm hey guys
thank you council hull against
thank you jarvis
and
thank you cancer stamp for tara thank
you
thank you cancer stilts
swain paul councillor mrs thompson
against that star
the results of that are 14 4 12 against
and one abstention
thank you thank you tara that
is agreed thank you members
um
right i think we can move on to six now
can't we high street
reset and recovery uh so we'll move then
to this agenda item
high street reset and recovery malden
high street consultation found on pages
three two seven two three three
two and in a moment i'll call on the
leader to present this item
and again members if you want to speak
on this item please make this known
using the hands up function
and i will come to you in turn please
keep your points
clear and succinct leader please
introduce the report
thank you chair um this is
this report is actually for noting um i
is my understanding i'll check with mr
dodson
uh please yes thank you chair so the
high street reset and recovery modern
high street consul
consultation purpose of the report is
listed in 1.1 1.2 1.3
i don't need to read the app members i'm
sure we've all read it
so i'd like to move the recommendation
that members note the significant work
that has been undertaken to support mold
and high street
including the survey undertaken and to
note that this work will now be taken
forward
as part of business as usual and with
the already agreed policies
within the local dependent development
plan uh chairman do i can i ask for a
second of that report
please please
thank you thank you so
chad can i hand over to uh mr dodson if
he wishes to speak on this
on this report but it like i say it is
for noting
thank you yes mr leslie
sorry was it mr dodson sorry sorry i've
maybe got the wrong officer i do
apologise
thank you chairman um yes um this report
is for noted
by members and it gives members a
summary and clarification of the way in
which various work streams regarding
malden high street will now be taken
forward
the report provides an update for
members on the recent work
and consultation um undertaken regarding
malden high street
the consultation responses were largely
supportive
of giving priority to the pedestrian in
the high street
and supportive of the policies that
already exist within the council's
adopted central area master plan
spd and the supplement that supplements
policy s5 for the local development plan
work was undertaken in the summer of
2020 looking at options for the high
street
this work and the evidence it produced
will now be taken forward via the
existing central area master plan
approach
and will be informed by this transport
strategy work that has been undertaken
with partners including essex county
council
this along with the approved air quality
management area
plan action plan approved in july 2020
will inform any future proposals which
will be developed through our business
as usual processes
this will include that any emerging
proposals for a modern high street will
be presented to
a future meeting of council for approval
members should also know the opportunity
to secure funding for a feasibility
study to consider a potential
sustainable transport link to whittam
again should this be successful any
outcome would be reported to full
council
officers don't normally bring forward
reports for note him but it was felt
appropriate that a member update was
provided in this case for information
thank you chairman thank you mr dodson
councillor lagan
you wish to speak thank you chair i i i
know the reports for noting so i'm going
to be brief
um and i appreciate the significant work
that the officers have done as i do in
in every state
although i i feel there are many flaws
in some of the strategies that we're
going for
here um and i wait to to see some of the
recommendations as work is progressed
which you should
but i just want to raise to all members
uh uh based on a lot of conversations
that i've had with a significant
proportion of people that use the high
street
that that some of these ideas have a
potential to be flawed and made of
damage
it's just a concern it doesn't mean i'm
not appreciative of what people are
doing
but i am concerned that some of the
strategies that could actually impact
negatively going forward
for generations to come thank you chair
thank you council again i mean as you
say it is for noting
and uh everything will come to council
uh and we'll have the opportunity to
speak further on that
uh members this is for noting can we um
so i've got another hand up somewhere i
can't quite see whose that is can you
assist me tara
yes of course chairman's counselor swain
and councillor fleming have both got
their hands up thank you
okay uh councillor swain oh yes thank
you chairman
this is just noting this report
well note yes but it includes a
recommendation
um i know the recommendation i'm sorry
the recommendation is to note it
uh this this will all come back to
council if you if you have further
further items but that is the
recommendation just to note it
well i think far too much is placed on
the
high street um consultation and
it cannot be used as a justification for
carrying forward some of the ideas
for dealing with covid or the market
hill air quality problem or the central
area mark
master plan there are three different
issues and they have three different
um answers all right okay i appreciate i
appreciate what you're saying
all of these will have all of these
positions
all of these will be coming to council
this report here is merely to note the
work uh that's being done
uh and so uh that's what i want to uh
to to move on to it's not just noting it
it's saying how it will be used
sorry i'm sorry it is for noting that's
what it's for
i'm sorry but it is councillor fleming
you chair just quickly um just following
on from what councillor swain was saying
i note his concerns and actually just to
reassure him
i was going to propose that the next
covert
reset working group that actually we
undertake some pedestrian surveys
because the floor with the consultations
of course is that you rely on people to
come to you
we actually need to go to residence
on the street and we need to properly
map out
where the pedestrians are thank you
thank you very much members you're asked
nearly to note this report uh are you
happy to do that by ascent
agreed
thank you i'm now going to move on to
agenda item
7 which was the brad will be closed down
program closed down and local
development plan review
in a moment i will call on the leader to
present this item found on pages
333-354 um again members
if you wish to
speak on this please use the hands up
function and i will come to you
in turn please keep your points clear
and
succinct leader please present the
report
uh thank you mr chair um well members
the
purpose of the report is to consider the
implications of the bradwell b
programme closed down and the
opportunity to bring forward
the review of the local development plan
utilizing work that has already
commenced
as much as possible and redeploying the
fixed term staffing resources from the
bradwell b project uh chairman i would
like to make the recommendations as
follows and
asked for ask do ask for a second and
once i've made the recommendations i
will reach
out in the entirety chairman so
recommendation little one
is that the impacts of the brad will be
project closed down and funding
withdrawal be noted
little too chairman that members agree
that there's an opportunity
to bring forward the review of the
modern district local development plan
including utilizing staff from the
bradwell team where possible to
accelerate delivery chair
and little three that members consider
the uh and approve the modern district
local development scheme
2021 to 2024 as set out in appendix one
do i have a second to please check
council amaze
picture thank you i will now
invite members to make any comments on
that report
tara has anyone indicated that they wish
to speak please
chairman and the officer may wish to
speak sorry i failed in my duty there i
should have handed it over to mr dodson
so i do apologize to yourself and to
members
and to mr johnson of course mr dodson
sorry about that
thank you chairman as the leader said
the purpose of this report is to enable
members to consider the implications of
the closed down of the council's
bradwell b
programme and the opportunity this gives
to bring forward the review of the local
development plan
and redeploying the the fixed term staff
resources from the bradwell b
project to work on the ldp review as we
reported to council earlier this month
uh the bradwell b team will be closed
following the withdrawal of the brb
funding
that was provided to deal with the dco
process
the council was advised of this at the
end of january and it reflects the
decision by brb to spend the next 12
months focusing on design and technical
issues
rather than the dco process associated
with bradwell
in setting the 2021-22 budget
earlier in this meeting consideration
was given to the need to review the ldp
and budget was assigned to undertake
this process
the approval of this budget along with
the availability of staff from the
bradwell team
enables us to refocus their duties on
the ldp
which will have the effect of
accelerating the delivery of the ldp
review
reducing the use of external consultants
in that process
and it will also retain the expertise
we've developed in the bradwell
team when the dco element of the
bradwell project resumes
in bringing forward the ldp review it's
also been necessary to update the local
development scheme
which is the formal document that sets
out the council's planning policy
program in relation to all local
development plan related issues
the updated lds plan is also presented
for member approval
thank you chairman thank you mr dodson
um tara has any members indicated that
they wish
uh to speak please oh no chairman no one
has indicated they want to speak
thank you okay in that case uh i'll go
to
the recommendations uh one two and three
are our members happy to agree those
recommendations by ascent
agreement you agree great great
thank you very much um in that case
members i thank you for your
contributions this evening
i'm going to draw this meeting to a
close at
7 56 and as the meeting is now closed
members are advised not to enter into
any further discussion
on this forum and please leave the
meeting
promptly thank you very much